foreign
do not like sex I think the word I use
is like I resent it it feels very
mandatory I also just have this feeling
like I genuinely don't need it it's
causing issues because I know my husband
needs it I was gonna say are you married
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney's show
man I'm so glad you've joined us on this
special series of episodes we're putting
together tomorrow is Valentine's Day
tomorrow's Valentine's Day and I know a
lot of you like oh dude I hate
Valentine's day bro it's such a
corporate shut up it's Valentine's Day
and we wanted to celebrate it by taking
calls that deal with love sex marriage
all of it all of it so today is the
first of two themed shows where we focus
on nothing but relationship sex intimacy
and relationships are not just like
about oh
or the stuff you see in Hallmark movies
right those movies that Kelly watches
all the actually Kelly doesn't she's
more of a
uh law order SVU that's more of like Ben
Ben is all about the uh romantic
comedies the Hallmark 100 so for the
next two shows we're gonna pull back the
curtain and we're gonna talk about real
questions about real relationships are
we talking about real questions about
sex so
if you get little kids I don't know
maybe maybe not the series maybe I don't
know let them go watch Bluey and maybe
you sit down with somebody that you love
and y'all can listen to the shows
together buckle up so looking forward to
it and uh Kelly you told me we're gonna
kick off today with the lightning round
oh my God
ah fantastic
I would have got a velvet coat man or a
lava lamp that was good man I like that
some Swisher Sweets that would have been
good dude way to go
fantastic all right so lightning round
so if you for those of you who have
never been with us on a lightning round
I have absolutely 100 no idea what
they're about to ask and so they're just
gonna bring the Thunder
which is a terrible thing to say for the
uh sex intimacy you're gonna you're
gonna ask a lot of questions yes and
these are all under the sex and intimacy
category awesome so buckle up everybody
but let's let's go or unbuckle there you
go yeah all right let's do it all right
the first one what do you mean when you
say that you have to practice desire
oh man
um
we as a culture we worship at the altar
of our feelings and so we think that if
I don't feel quote unquote in love I
don't feel quote unquote attracted I
don't feel whatever that that is the
end-all be-all that's the truth and
that's it's feelings are very very
important they're important signals that
you need to feel and ask yourself what
are they telling you same as if you're
driving on the road and there's flashing
neon signs in front of you while you're
driving in traffic you need to look at
those signs but that's not the
destination that's not where you're
going right so when it comes to
practicing desire what I mean is
desire over time is a choice it is
something not that is just like it's not
a whim it's not just a well that's just
the way that is no dude practicing
desire is important and so I'm gonna
practice
taking care of myself so that I'm I'm my
best I'm gonna practice
um meeting my partner's needs I'm gonna
practice leaning in and having hard
conversations or really sexy intimate
conversations Etc so that's practicing
desire that's what I mean when I say
that
all right you've mentioned before that
some people can't have sex with dirty
dishes in the sink
how do I find without how do I find out
what those things are for my spouse
oh ready this is good I own you a lot of
grad school for this this answer
um
drum roll please America
you ask ta-da
um I think I think if you are a couple
on the same page you're a couple that's
like hey here's where we are with our
sex life and here's what we would like
it to be
we want it to be less
um chores less
um like I got a checklist and more let's
see if we can get the wallpaper to peel
itself off the wall right that's that's
going ahead
the conversation often couples jump in
and they start with what sex act do you
want to try and that's fun that's
exciting it's it's a blast but I
wouldn't recommend starting there most
of the time most of the time you back up
and say okay
what is a world where you feel the most
sexy
if you go back to the last two or three
times four or five times when you have
I've gotten home and you just want to
get it on what was going on in that
world and want to begin to listen to our
bodies as we move forward so if you find
yourself about to get it on and you're
thinking about the dishes call it out
because we're practicing this thing
together as we move forward so call that
out or dude I've just got to go make
sure the downstairs basement's locked up
oh okay weird but go make sure it's
locked up or maybe next time I'm gonna
make sure it's locked up before I head
upstairs so listen to your body over
time
cool all right my spouse over shares
about our relationship to his family and
friends how do I tell him to stop
again man you lucked out with a genius
like me hang on to your hats America
tell him to stop
ta-da I
number one tell them stop number two
here's how I would frame that
um I don't feel safe
when parts of my intimate private life
are shared among other people it makes
me feel exposed and unsafe please don't
make me feel unsafe
that is a language that is different
than I don't want you to or why do you
that's different
um get to the root of why you don't want
someone to know and it may be it may be
like you can get to the bottom of me
like I don't know I'm just overreacting
I just think talking about sex is weird
and I guess it's not
um that might be you and it might be I
you feel so viscerally exposed you feel
uncomfortable you feel whatever the
thing is
um speak there not just at the I want my
way but at the here's how you make me
feel
I feel like that buzzer is like saying
wrong answer it's so good it is a bit
hard wrong
all right so if your partner initiates
sex but you don't want to at that moment
should you still do it
man why you gotta set me up like that
um
jeez this one's a tricky one
so here's how it is I'll answer this in
multiple ways
if you don't want to because your
partner hurts you or you are being
abused or you know your partner or
assume your partner is cheating on you
it might be bringing somebody else's
diseases into your bed or whatever
no
absolutely not
if
you or somebody man or woman I don't
care who takes some time to warm up or
you're tired you're not quote unquote
feeling it right now
but you know over time if you just like
Let It Ride you start getting into it
then you're you're never glad that you
you're never not glad that you went
ahead and did it right so if that's you
then yes then I need to know I'm really
tired right now I just want to go to bed
I am not gonna regret in fact I'm gonna
really be happy myself with myself if we
go ahead and do this and I can tell my
partner's really into it so
um it that's not a is that a safe answer
I don't be a safe answer but it feels
right
yes because I think that's where the
question's Leaning it's that
you know everybody's safe in the room
and everything like that but is that man
I'm so tired but then like you said
but I'm always glad we do exactly
halfway through I'm like okay this was a
much better decision than watching the
office right right
um I think listen to your body and also
be honest with yourself like if you know
in 10 or 15 minutes you're gonna be glad
you're into this then go for it man
um and it goes back to that idea like
feelings are important signals but
they're not truth tellers and
um yeah I really want to just double
click on the on the abuse thing man if
you don't feel like it because you're
not safe because you just like your
partner doesn't care about your needs at
all and it's all about him getting off
or her what if if that's the case not in
that moment but you need to have a
conversation about a much harder broader
conversation
all right this one's a little longer so
bear with me what do you mean when you
tell partners that their spouse is not
something to fix
when an individual in a relationship has
baggage that they need to work through
how do you do this without coming at
them from a fixing standpoint
um
the best example I gave you is last
night my my wife and I went for a long
walk like we like we've we've started
doing the last year or so and they're I
just love it
um we're going for a long walk and she
was walking me through some things she's
been thinking through and working
through and I said
could I give you a word of caution
and her response was no thank you
and I had to
exhale for a second
and then moving on with my day and it
was a bold moment of strength for her to
say no thank you and I was trying to
love her the best I could but what she
didn't need for me in that moment
evident by her telling me so was my Wiz
my my wisdom my advice my answers
what she needed was a safe place to tell
what she's working through what she's
thinking about what she's feeling and
what she's going to do next and part of
Love often is letting somebody
do their thing and to be with them when
they're doing it to be with them when
it's super successful and be with them
when it falls in on itself and so
um I I think go back to the original
question there oh about fixing
I think all of this can be solved with a
very simple phrase seek to be
um
with not over
when you start giving advice
the posture everything about advice is I
know something you don't know I'm in an
elevated position from you
I can see what's happening and you can't
um that is different than I'll sit here
with you I know what I would do but man
I don't have all the answers either and
I'm not you and seek to be with seek to
be with seek to be with
um husbands especially have a tendency
we just are loved by our utility what
can you do you're a human doing right
and so when people in our lives are
hurting we just want to go fix it wanna
make it right because that's how we
achieve love
that's not how relationships work over
time
foreign
ER wants to try something new in the
bedroom and I'm not comfortable with it
what should I do
see I'm not comfortable with it
um I think there's a uh again this isn't
every couple and there's jerks and
idiots everywhere
um
often I think when couples get stuck on
like I want to try this one sex move I
want to trust one position I'll try this
one thing
um the instant response is I'm not doing
that sometimes that response is I'm not
doing that because I've never seen it I
don't even know what are you talking
about that sounds weird that sounds like
it's going to be awful it's whatever
you're feeling so you're instantly
trying to protect yourself which is
which is great
um
and your partner can often feel like
oh there's there's a part of me that you
don't love because I'm interested in
this and you're not right so you get
this weird tension often I've seen that
diffused with
like some laughter and some okay like
what do you why do you want to do that
like what is it about that thing and
often there's some eroticism around
talking about well it would feel good if
and I want to try this and I think you
are feeling the blank like getting to
the bottom of why you want to try that
what you're thinking about what are some
alternative things we could do or I'll
try this instead of that becomes an
erotic conversation in and of itself if
you'll allow it if it doesn't become
this uh
Ike fight like I want to do this and you
never let then you're just an idiot but
if you are really getting to the bottom
of how do you why do you want to try
that
um then I think I think I think you can
get there and it's a lot more fun
all right on the flip side of that how
do you bring up something new that you
want to try but you're unsure if your
partner will be comfortable comfortable
with it
so I have developed I didn't develop
anything
um
so two years ago I did a live event uh
and I said hey here's what everyone
needs to do um it's for it's gonna cost
like 15 cents go to Walgreens and buy
like 10 or 15 just envelopes empty
envelopes and I call it the John deloney
erotic envelope system and go buy 10 or
15 envelopes get note cards and you get
five and she gets five you get seven and
she gets whatever
and just write down
what something you want to you want to
do
whatever
let the what do you let the freak flag
fly whatever like I really want to try
this I want to try this I want to try
this and
uh is my wife put in one time I just
opened it up and oh here's like once a
month once a week whatever just commit
we're gonna give it the old College try
we're gonna open this up and we're gonna
figure this out it may not work it may
be a disaster but we're gonna go into it
with a spirit of exploration and fun and
laughter and not a and again going back
to if you open it up and you're like I
don't know how this is physically pot
like what have that conversation make
that a fun like how does this even what
are you talking about right have that
conversation uh my wife one time uh
she put on one french kissing
oh I felt like I got robbed
it was just French kissing she's like we
used in college we just french kissed
and I like that and I miss it
so that was in the envelope and that's
what we did
just held Hansen
made out it was awesome so anyway all I
have to say is put whatever you want in
there I just want to go hold your hand
on 30 minutes I Want to Hold Your Hand
that's it that's it put it in the
envelope
um then what happens kind of questions
for humans it ends up being
I'm not the weird one the card is the
weird thing right so just a little bit
of deflection there where the card can
take some of the
what
um and let it let it roll what I will
tell you is this if you have something
you want to try or a couple of different
sex acts that your partner's not doing
and you want to get you
if you try over the course of two months
five months two years ten years to him
haul your way through it or to like kind
of subtly or not so subtly encourage it
you're setting up you're going to be
disappointed your partner is going to be
is going to know they're not doing
something right and they're not going to
know what it is and they're not going to
know how to talk about it you are
setting yourself up on a track of this
function don't do that don't hold
Secrets just say I want to try this
thing hopefully over time you develop
enough rapport with the person I don't
know you're going to make humans with
that you buy a house with that you can
say hey I'm into this thing I'm gonna
try it give it a shot give it a shot
that's all and also don't bully
oh for sure tell me more about that well
just don't bully your partner into well
I want to and you don't I don't get what
I want or you know if you love me stupid
and cowardly and lame yeah yeah
um yes don't don't be like that
absolutely just don't be like that
anywhere anywhere in Life or passive
aggressive like a gift you just don't
love me don't be like that it just gives
me the heebie-jeebies I hate passive
aggressiveness anyhow uh my spouse and I
don't share any of the same Hobbies so
we don't spend any free time together
how can we find something that we both
enjoy doing that was it what a great
question
um and I'm laughing because you have
whoever wrote the question has
bifurcated themselves into
they've backed themselves into a corner
and they've thrown their hands up and
they're like well we don't like any of
the same things and so now we don't we
don't get to spend time together
I would flip that around and say and say
we're gonna spend time together and with
the time we have left we're gonna spend
on our Hobbies right or maybe one day I
do Hobbies one day we spend time doing
things together and I think you figure
out things that you like to do together
over time
um for me and my wife often it's
reading a book next to each other
that's it because I don't like her book
she doesn't like my books we don't
listen to the same podcast we don't
listen to say like we have very
different like I play guitar she likes
to Garden we have very different things
that we do
um and so we have worked over time to
find those things where we can spend
time together and we have to be really
intentional about it and by the way
you just figured out over time and so
it's something you practice like man
I've been trying to
I mean she watched fights with me for
years she tried man she tried eventually
she's like all those guys are super
ripped they look great but I just I
gotta I want to go to bed and so I get
it and there's other things I've tried
like I'll try I'll try I just can't so
you give it a shot you give it a shot
and you practice and you try it and then
you move on I think this I'm gonna say
this
I think we make
every encounter the Super Bowl
every time we have sex it's the Super
Bowl it has to be mind-blowing both
people have to have an orgasm both
everything has to be just like this and
if it doesn't we start immediately going
okay what's wrong what didn't happen
right what
dude
if you spend most of your life like most
of life is a scrimmage we're just
practicing and figuring out it's so much
more fun you drop the ball in the
scrimmage like you and your friends
laugh at you you're teammates like idiot
it's not end of time it's not like in
front of 90 000 people or whatever
um it's so I think making taking the
pressure off of you and your spouse and
your friends
um on all things in your life man we're
just we're just fumbling through this
thing
that leads really nicely into this next
question oh look how cute that is to you
my fiance and I are about to get married
and we've saved ourselves for marriage
how do we not so put so much pressure on
one night
I I think it's insane
to not put pressure on that night it's
gonna be there like you know what I mean
um
to try to depressurize that situation is
is I wouldn't waste that energy the
energy I would expend would be talking
about it
super directly
and that might be weird if you are
waiting until
um you get married to enter into a
sexual relationship you may not have
spent a lot of time talking about it
here's what it's going to be like and my
friend told me it was like this
um talk to people in your life that you
trust who are down the road from you
right talk to other couples
um not maybe another couples but
individuals
have that conversation with each other
so there's some understanding of what
this thing might look like and by the
way it will be totally different than
you think and so I would head into it
that way and with the goal being
connectivity and closeness not
performance
across the board
is that fair it is but can I add
something you can add of all things
um
for the actual wedding night itself
you're exhausted oh you're so tired keep
that in mind that you're exhausted
because you've been planning this
wedding and this thing and it's huge and
it's a full day of family it's just a
it's a lot of a day it's an exhausting
day you probably when you're married you
probably wouldn't do it on that day any
other time throughout your history never
no you should be like I'm so tired I
don't I've been around people all day
long like I just want to go to bed yeah
so you probably wouldn't so that's what
I mean like you put so much pressure
like it's gonna be there because after
the wedding after all this stuff all the
people all those little yellow mints all
everything
all the dancing then you're like on the
right home to the hotel you're like I
guess this is happening like a whole
other and I've had some friends of mine
that have made agreements beforehand of
you know what we're going to be so tired
in the wedding we're not even gonna get
out of there until midnight
it's not gonna happen that night let's
party let's just call that
and then but that goes about talking
about it exactly right that goes about
like talking about it and
um I think it's like how do you what you
know we talk about pictures and words on
the show how do you picture
do you picture me taking off your
clothes do you picture you taking them
all like how do you like let's
let's have that conversation and that
way you don't end up having I'm saying
that and I'm watching these like hearts
fly around my heads in through the
monitor here it's so surreal but like I
think the more conversation you can have
the more you can set each other's
expectation and you can match your
pictures and words because again and I
was just doing an interview before the
show we're in the first generation
raised entirely on pornography right and
so somebody's gonna walk into that room
with an expectation of
something that's not real right and then
somebody may not be connected to
pornography at all or somebody may have
been like I don't know what I'm doing
and they went down to pornography rabbit
hole and they so I think setting
expectations intentionally is good and
by the way talking about sex can be one
of the most intimate fun hilarious
sexy things you can do if you can
develop the the ability to have that
conversation between yourselves all
right last one
the things that turned my spouse on and
the things that turned me on are
completely different
how do we find common ground
sometimes you
participate in somebody else's fantasy I
think you in and I use fantasy brought I
guess if you don't dress up like Pirates
dressed up like Pirates but I'm seeing
more like I
um I just I'm just working with couples
like one like really gets in the mood
from like holding hands and touching and
it's quiet and then somebody else like
wants somebody to take charge and
somebody else wants somebody to just
feel like it so I think it's a saying
those needs out loud and B
um tonight we're gonna have I really
want to have boring married sex I wanna
have just regular boring marriage sex
tonight I really want to have some sort
of storyline I want to have some sort of
thing that's out there
um that I've conjured up in my head that
I want to like participate with you like
so I think it's a matter of there's some
give and take there
um and then if if there's some things
again going back to the original
question if we just feel uncomfortable
um I think you need to say out loud like
these things are making me uncomfortable
okay so that's it all right that was the
last one you did a very nice job wraps
up the lightning round hey uh before we
head out if you have here's what I'm
looking for I'm looking for this is a
funny
ask on the back end of a lightning round
about sex I'm looking for success
stories not doing it success stories I'm
looking for I mean I guess so are you
happy to send them in
um Kelly's like please don't please
don't I'm the one that reason she
screams no thank you yes
um send in your success stories if we've
been doing the show for a couple years
now if you and your wife y'all have
changed the way you communicate if
you've changed the way you parent
um if you have stopped using drugs you
lost a bunch of weight you have gone
back to counseling if you've got a new
job send us the success stories in this
shows gets increasingly heavier by the
week and so I really want to be able to
put some light out into the world too uh
and so I would love to tell your success
story whether you're on the show or I
can just read your uh your letter I
would love to put some more light out
there so
um send them to John deloney.com ask ask
and just put success story into
headlines all right we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor better help
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is life
changing stuff but I'll be honest it's
not easy these are new skills that we
all have to learn and therapy is a great
place to practice these new skills and
that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back let's go to Tom in
Cleveland Ohio what's up Tom
hey John how's it going good man go
Bengals what's up dude hey absolutely
absolutely wrong town but I'll go for
them the Browns aren't in anymore I was
gonna say at this point you all just
need to be cheering for any ohioan group
right
that's right yeah all right so what's up
dude so John I had a question
um I I wrote down a little bit of it but
main question is uh how to reunite with
my wife and marriage um and kind of a
big story behind that I did start my own
business in 2018 and I think that's kind
of what started it all
um she kind of took where I'm married uh
to my beautiful wife since 2014.
um but she was doing the finances at the
time then of course when I you know got
into my own business uh I started
looking you know into the finances
numbers stuff like that and started
doing budgeting then I I noticed you
know I thought we were under
overspending and it turned into you know
trying to put the blame on her turned
into arguments over a two-year you know
period and it turns you know it turned
out to be I was being more like a dad to
her than her husband I was just about to
say that man yeah good for you good for
you for catching that
and I yeah I really I mean I I own up to
it I know what you know it happened in
you know long story short I wasn't her
safe place anymore now I mean I I did
commit myself about a year and a half
ago you know no more haggling over you
know overspending and stuff like that
um you know do it together which has
been good
although I I don't think we're back to
where we can just you know openly talk
cuddle you know simply enjoy each other
every day and date
and
how do I
be that husband for her that she adores
you know
to be that safe space again
yeah number one do you just want to
applaud you man I wish every husband in
America would have the courage and the
strength to do what you've done which is
to look in the mirror and say I I
was doing the best I could with the
tools I had and those tools ended up
making a bigger mess than helping and I
want to I want to do something different
I want to be better good for you man
that's hard Tom that's hard so I want
you to own that okay
um
you're not gonna like my answer is that
cool
absolutely okay I'm I'm open and I'll
also say that a lot of the Beefcake like
yeah bro let's go snap into a slim jim
guys who listen to the show are gonna
naturally be like oh yeah whatever dude
and when I give you the answer okay and
I don't care because I'm right
and usually I'm like ah maybe I'm right
on this okay
you have gone away basically what you've
done is you have
um how to cease fire
you have not dealt with issues of peace
right
right and so
what's beneath the question what's
beneath your concern about overspending
so the magic you want to connect with
your wife reconnect with your wife
it's not on how many bullets are being
fired it's not you're spending too much
at Costco you're just blowing we can eat
for way cheaper than that why are you
spending so much it's not that
it is
I'm I'm starting a new business
and I'm terrified that I'm gonna wreck
the family finances
I am
scared to death about money because I
grew up and I didn't have any money
growing up and I want to be a better
husband than my dad was for us and I
don't know how to do it I'm trying and
when I see numbers like this my body
just reacts in a terrified way
the magic word here is vulnerability
it's being honest with your wife not
about how smart you are and how good you
are at Excel spreadsheets and how in
nitpicking all the things she buys or
doesn't buy
beneath that is I can't breathe I'm
scared to death
we're staring down the barrel of a
recession I'm afraid we're going to lose
customers I'm trying to hang on to my
new business whatever is going on
people don't connect with one another
over strength
they can accomplish great things they
can become Partners but you deepen a
relationship through vulnerability
does that make sense
that makes 100 sense and that that a
while back ago we had a good
conversation and completely openness and
it it was like um
you know
a couple hundred pounds off the
shoulders yeah and and um I was just I
I'm uh I'm in the middle of editing uh
my book manuscript here is a straight
and I don't know if I mentioned this on
the show the other day I was having a
conversation with somebody about it
this is strange to me that it I had
never thought this through but up until
like a hundred or maybe 200 years ago
everybody lived in a house that was
relative like one room right maybe there
was a second room for the grown-ups but
everyone lived in one room
and so everybody knew if somebody had
diarrhea or if somebody was sick or if
somebody hooked up with so and so
the idea of Secrets is new
right the idea that I can go in my room
shut my door put a podcast in and go to
a completely different planet than my
kids and my spouse that I can pick up a
book and go down a rabbit hole or watch
my own series on my iPad in my room with
the door shut with my headphones on
our bodies aren't designed for that why
do I tell you that
what you just said the 200 pounds like
off your back
there is a biology to secrets secrets
will kill you
and secrets come out that angst you feel
that weight you feel about I feel like
when we're sleeping together you're not
fully with me and it makes me nervous it
makes me feel like I'm I'm alone it
makes me feel like right it comes out as
we don't ever have enough sex
or you don't ever do anything cool and
or you say nothing you see what I'm
saying and the secret is way down there
which is
man we're we're we're we're sleeping
together we are sharing a house we're
raising kids together but we are two
inches apart and 2 000 miles away from
each other all of that my brother I
don't care how tough you are how strong
you are how big your truck is well you
served in the military I don't care what
it it all starts with vulnerability
sitting in front of somebody and saying
this is what terrifies me about where we
are right now
and here's the ugly thing about
vulnerability she can roast you
right she can destroy you oh my little
pansy husband is just whining now oh
great you want me to here's your violin
and wives will do that it's awful
it's it's heartbreaking because the they
want to be adored they want to be loved
and the only way they can be truly loved
is if their husband has a space where
they can be safe and say I'm scared too
and that's just the world we've got
right now somebody's got to go first and
I'm pointing at you man go first so tell
me one thing what are you scared about
brother
well I I think you nailed it you know
just with the business although you know
financially it's not really uh
um a struggle but it does cross my mind
you know every day with uh you know gosh
what if this thing's goes you know goes
belly up but
um you know it's been real good it's
been real good I got you know a good
support from her from the start and
like like I said I didn't notice that
that I was pushing it on her until you
know two years in and and uh you know I
I really regret it now but so let me let
me tell you something my wife told me um
so
uh I I've worked in education for my
whole career
and without realizing it I'd worked in
non-profits my whole career I didn't I
didn't mean to never set out to I just
did
and in the the universities and the in
the schools that I worked at
um I got a salary
and I work 24 7 365 and my salary was
always the same
and then I got this job
and if I write another book
at night instead of sleeping instead of
hanging out with my kids I make more
money
if I take another speaking gig even
though I'm exhausted I gotta get on a
plane and fly to another city for two
hours and then get another I make a lot
more money
and so in the first three years of
working here I went crazy I've never
experienced this before and over uh it
was a few months ago now my wife
sat me down and said I get to speak into
this too because this is my house too
and this is our life we're building it's
not your job this is our life and she
said
the money bucket is full
and what she was telling me was
and she also said the same thing about
my obsession with working out all the
time
she said
I am as attracted to you as I can be
like one more pound lost isn't going to
be like oh there it is and it's not like
I'm as attracted to you as I can be
so any more Obsession you have with
getting more ripped or more cut or more
what she said that's your problem that's
not for us
foreign you make plenty of money
any more money you need to go get is
because of your ego not because of your
wife and kids need it
and that was a huge conversation for me
and so I tell you that Tom to sit down
with her and give her a safe space
maybe start with I haven't given you a
safe space I haven't created a place
where you could even say your needs out
loud
what buckets are full
is it time for me to hire somebody so
that I can be home more and take some of
the burden off of you I can help with
bedtime with the kids I can take them
for walks so that you can shower by
yourself or use the bathroom by yourself
whatever stage you'll happen to be in
um and we're gonna make less money
because I'm gonna hire somebody at work
and that's okay that's the season we're
in
or actually she's terrified about
finances too and so I'm actually gonna
work a side hustle I'm gonna I'm gonna
get another job and I'm gonna work crazy
for 14 months to get us at a position so
that right
but let her maybe for the first time
speak into
this world
because I want to change the
conversation in this country she's not
supporting your job
y'all are doing life together
and she may have a supporting role I
don't even like that language she's got
a equally and powerful and important
role it may not come with a paycheck but
it sure keeps the ship going right and
you can be the best fisherman in the
world but if it's not somebody driving
the ship or if the ship's got holes in
it you ain't catching fish or you could
catch a lot of fish you're gonna sink to
the bottom of the ocean and so the
supporting and like she's my she's my
number one fan and my support S no dude
it's a it's a team effort let her speak
into that but all of that starts with
you going first and you being that word
that we all hate man there's just not a
way around it
being vulnerable
saying I'm scared to death and I can't
breathe
I haven't been a guy that I wanted to be
what kind of husband do you need in this
season and how can I help create a world
where you feel safe
how can I meet your needs so that you
have the capacity to help me meet my
needs
go first man go first it's it's an honor
to talk to you Tom I wish more men had
the courage and bravery and strength
that you do hopefully they'll listen to
this call and be inspired thanks for
being brave man we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back let's go out to
Gretchen in Pittsburgh what's up
Gretchen
hi Dr John this is cool hearing you
through my phone I listen to you all the
time on YouTube it's cool hearing you
through my phone very cool what's up
so my question for you is
um I oh gosh how do I say this I really
hey Gretchen we are way past that on
this show just say whatever I know I
know I know but it's always more
nerve-wracking once with you
um so I really do not like sex okay
um I I think the word I use is like I
resent it I resent
checks as a whole partially just I think
it's due to a lot of things for me it's
it feels very mandatory
um I also just have this feeling like I
genuinely don't need it I don't want it
um and it's causing issues because I
know my husband needs it I was gonna say
are you married I am married I've been
married for
um about 15 months and I actually didn't
I did not have sex before marriage I was
a virgin when I got married
um and we kind of didn't anticipate any
issues in in this regard because
granted even in the confines of trying
to remain a virgin before marriage you
know you still you make out and and you
feel a passionate connection towards one
another and then I got married and I
feel like felt like it went away
um and now it's to the point where
I have absolutely no interest in having
sex with my husband at all none
um and I'm not 100 sure why I could
probably come up with a list of possible
reasons but I just and I'm kind of at a
point where I don't really know what to
do about it because I know
well I may not need it I know he needs
it and it's getting very challenging for
me because I'm just kind of in this
please don't touch me I don't want to be
touched I don't I don't feel like this
doing this today and even on the times
that I kind of muster up enough to have
sex with my husband
I mean I enjoy it
once I get there but getting there
is like very hard for me yeah
um and I'm and again I'm at a point
where I like
I don't really know what to do about it
and I want to fix it because I I want to
want to have sex of course but I I don't
excellent well number one thank you for
saying that out loud
I imagine you're not telling a whole
bunch of people that is that fair
no I think I've mentioned it to two
girlfriends okay one agreed with me and
one was like what are you talking about
okay I'm gonna run through so number one
I want you to know you are absolutely
not crazy you're not alone okay and not
alone to the tune of millions okay so
you're not nuts
cool good thank you yes
um
I'm gonna run through a series of
questions that I always ask folks in
this situation okay
yes
um but before I do that I want to
at first acknowledge
it happens a lot for people who uh
choose to remain a virgin until they're
married
is that sex becomes
to to use religious imagery becomes an
idol it becomes a thing that is going to
solve and fix all things
and it's going to be
um
like you probably heard it said in your
religious organization your bodies will
just know what to do and it will just be
this sinking up and this magic whatever
and I'm just I I just don't think that's
accurate
um yeah I'll agree and so there's this
powerful pressure put on it
and not only that as a woman you have
this performance pressure and this
Instagram World pressure that you've got
to compete with fill in the blanks all
those things
um you and your husband or how old are
you I'm 25. yeah so I was just talking
about this earlier on in the show y'all
both were raised in a culture whether
you all participated or not that was
raised entirely by pornography
and so the either the images or that
this is what it's supposed to look like
and this is we're all supposed to be
screaming and yelling and having chaos
and it's supposed to be fun and exciting
and the wallpapers are supposed to fall
off the walls on its own and the house
catches on fire that's the world that
we've all that you've been handed this
is what it's supposed to look like and
there's no playbook for the weird
awkward what are you do that is real sex
especially as a couple's getting to know
each other right yeah there's no and so
everything feels like failure screwing
up I don't like this and depending on
our bodies
some of our and this is about experience
this is about genetics this is about a
whole Cascade of things
some bodies respond to failure and to
this isn't working right and this isn't
what looks this what wasn't what my
picture was
they respond to that by running head in
head first into that burning building
they're fire men and women they run
straight in I'm going to solve this
problem let's keep working on it and
other people
get out of the building they shut the
thing down right
so I just want to start this before I
ask you questions like start by
acknowledging man you guys have built a
hella pressure to live up to right
so number one are you
um
do you have any abuse in your past
no okay
none that you can think of or just no
all good I guess I guess
in context
um sexual abuse no
no uh my dad's a little rough around the
edges and I think there's some emotional
trauma that comes with that but I
wouldn't consider it abuse okay so it
depends on your definition
okay
um
are you on any sort of birth control
no no just rocking and rolling
uh yeah I learned how to Natural family
plan
um and when doing a lot of my research I
just determined that that was the best
way to go and so far I've had no issues
okay
um and I'm smiling every time someone's
like nah dude we're just we're just
student natural those are always my
friends that ended up with their kids
first but you do you you do you oh
um okay so and the reason I asked that
is
it before I did anything I would go see
my doctor about hormones
okay 100 percent
before you do anything else we have any
more conversations before you go see a
counselor I would have you go get your
hormones checked
um the hormone regulation is all over
the place and depending on what Rabbit
Hole you go down it can be diet related
it can be you know experientially it can
be genetic who cares who it just is so I
would go have all of those things
checked have you done that
I have not okay so that's a good idea
okay I would do that third is your
husband
you love him I know that
is he a jerk or a bully or a
why won't you do this or I want this
um yeah pretty much okay
that has to stop because your body I
know your body's trying to protect you
yeah I a feeling that was what the
answer to this was going to be
tell me about him
um
so we met I'm actually
really moved to Pittsburgh when I after
I graduated from college and
he is someone who has an addictive
personality he's also incredibly
particular
and
it leads to just like endless nitpicking
about the most ridiculously little
things some of it seems unnecessary a
lot of the times I deal with it I have a
pretty thick skin so you know I kind of
let it roll off my back I think the
problem is is that it doesn't really
roll on my back nope and then it
manifests in other ways like this vessel
vanderkolk wrote the book and the title
of the book is the body keeps the score
yeah you can be tough Buffalo gal all
day long and Buffalo Gals are tough make
no mistake right
um but
I your body might say oh you're not
leaving okay cool we're shutting the
system down
yeah I think that's what's been going on
and a lot of times especially new
couples
with and again I say this with all due
respect and if he was on the phone I
would say this to him directly okay
um
he can have a quote unquote addictive
personality or he can have OCD or he can
have Ada she can have all these things
he can also be an ass
right
yeah so you can have all that stuff
great that's a context it's not an
excuse to be disrespectful to your wife
it's not an excuse to not help create an
environment where she feels her body
feels safe enough to be sexual
and nitpicking and one of them hey man
why are you wearing that oh my gosh you
need to lose five pounds all that crap
like that's creating a world that sex
becomes it it's a place that sex
intimacy can't inhabit because the world
is so toxic
and here's what often happens you become
his mom
you start taking over responsibility for
making sure he feels okay
and it's really hard to have sex with
your kids
yeah I think
I think of my childhood
kind of again playing into making sure
that my dad stays calm or quiet or
whatever and I think this feels very
similar okay um and so instead of like
necessarily your kid it feels more like
very it's very similar to my childhood
gotcha okay there we go so
um here's here's your
here's your path forward okay and I'm
gonna tell you is can you be real honest
with me
sure uh is he abusive
no
emotionally
I don't let him be emotionally abusive
that sounds really tough and cool and I
appreciate you uh flexing is he
emotionally abusive
I don't know I really don't know if I
can answer that like I sometimes
let me put it struggling to say yes
because I don't really want to say yes
because I don't know if I could
I don't want to say yes okay I will
leave you to deal with your reality but
you know the truth
you also know that guys can wrap
themselves up and I'm a good guy and
they can be hyper abusive without ever
saying a word
their presence can hover around a home
like a grizzly bear
and when you ask them dude what's wrong
why are you just when I'm wrong you're
like driving me crazy because you always
nitpicking me I'm just sitting here
watching TV bullcrap dude that whole
thing was a flex just as much as if
someone was yelling and screaming and
smashing glasses up against the wall
it's just a slow nuclear reactor burn
and if you grew up with that in your
home your body knows you better
disappear kid
right
yeah it it puts a like peacemaking
filter on because that's what I did as a
child I was The Peacemaker of the
household right and so then that becomes
the priority of how do we end the
conflict and I will say I am sometimes
equally as guilty as being explosive
sure but it takes me
I think a lot longer to get there than
it does
and he's not explosive and angry it's
just
the criticism is never ending right
so here's what y'all are in desperate
need of number one before today's over I
want you to make a doctor's appointment
to go get all of your hormone levels
checked okay it's gonna cost money it's
gonna be pain in the butt go get it done
okay even if nothing else you're 25 it'd
be a great Baseline to have as you get
older okay
second thing is you all need to call a
marriage counselor today
and if he won't go
tell them we have to learn how to
communicate because I'm not safe in this
marriage anymore
my body's shutting itself down
and I've got to find a different way to
live
I want you to come with me
and when you go to counseling you are
going to have to risk him getting up and
walking out
with your honesty by saying things like
I'm not safe with you here or you I've
you've got to stop criticizing me
because I can't stand before you with no
clothes on and say do you love me if
you're always criticizing me criticizing
me and criticizing me and blaming me I
can't do that
he's got to hear that from you and it
sounds like he is not safe enough or or
that would be a smart conversation for
you to have by yourself so you need to
go get a counselor and have that
conversation but what I'm telling you
overall is you take drastic action and
again we can talk about uh asexual and
people who just have no sex drive that's
a whole other conversation the last
thing I want you to do get emelina
gotsky's book come as you are ordered on
Amazon today and I want y'all to read it
together
Emily nagatski's come as you are read it
together and it will be awkward for
y'all to read together I get it
but it will give you all a new language
and a new way to have this conversation
about how do we create a world where my
body feels safe enough that sex becomes
exciting and fun
and what role are you husband gonna play
in helping me co-create that context
that world that environment that
ecosystem
go get that book today have us into your
house and you'll read it together
thank you so much for your trust and man
we will be rooting you on anytime you
want to call give me a shout we'll be
here we'll be right back
way undervalue real genuine
relationships our friendships our
marriages we don't know what we're doing
and instead of diving into the mess we
accept shallowness and distraction and
we wallpaper over our loneliness so let
me say this boldly you cannot be well
alone you've got to get connected to
real life people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John tony.com
all right that was episode one of sex
and marriage and intimacy week or
whatever we're calling this what are we
calling this thing
Valentine's week what up all right
song of the day is by the great Bruno
Mars and I don't know who Anderson pack
is
the group they formed a group called
Silk Sonic ah silk Sonic oh Bruno Mars
and AP song is called leave the door
open it goes like this
say baby say baby say baby
what you doing where you at oh you got
plans
don't say that
I'm sipping wine in a robe oh I'm out of
here dude
I look too good to be alone all right
that's all right hey love you guys we'll
see you soon